the more a girl looks like a hooker the
less she is a hooker exactly that's what
I'm saying that's very true that's
literally what I'm saying say that again
wait holders look like hookers they're
just prudes yeah
like oh I don't do that you just go to
all these innocent girls on the streets
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys it's it's about time we talk about
Megan Hall who that who's that she is
the MVP of the year doing what like WNBA
stuff stayed Famous by her activities
Police Department oh that's Megan I'm
not familiar go Megan go hey you know
she got it she got it oh the lady that
got fired for her welcome welcome to the
show
welcome you're
from the King has arrived I just know
her face dude I didn't know her name I
just know her face
that's crazy how she doesn't look like a
[__] freak you know what I mean they
usually don't they never do like a freak
yeah yeah you think so they look like
that totally give me give me give me the
look Anthony would know him right you
say they never do right so it's always a
freaking the one who's cleaning the
streets of the freaking machines do you
think your sister looks like a freak why
you gotta bring my sister into this I'm
just putting your theory to the test
obviously in the way your mom does her
stretches I know she's a freak
that's Jiu Jitsu baby
the more a girl looks like a hooker the
less she is a hook exactly that's what
I'm saying that's very true that's
literally what I'm saying say that again
wait holders look like hookers
nowadays they're just prunes yeah like
oh I don't do that you just go to all
these innocent girls on the streets I
know you're [__] free
yes the secretaries the Librarians the
[__] whatevers that are like learn to
be horny dude yeah isn't the [__] the
crypto guy like that whole crew was
[__] each other oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah they look [__] busted these
people yo everybody
wants to come that's the Golden Rule
that's true and then the more you can't
do it yo everybody wants to come JoJo
2024. so
in case you don't know she's a cop that
uh was uh fired for um having on the job
section the department with a number of
different offers you can get fired for
that all of on the job yeah in the
workplace aren't they chilling a lot of
the times though in certain areas they
were boning at different other events
outside of the force too like off the
job but then they also were having sex
and by the way not a lot of people know
how do you think she got caught
somebody snitched who do you think
snitched someone's wife nope a jealous
lover one of the dudes one of the cops
why would you do that he said he's like
she didn't suck my dick on Thursday
Thursday was my day but you know what's
weird is that he snitched so what he did
is he told I believe the mayor or
somebody else the mayor
of the [__] rat now all these guys
are aren't coming because of you and
then like I can't comment either I think
the mayor or somebody like filed a
complaint about it to the department
because he didn't get enough they didn't
know that it was this cop who told on
him and then so like that cop told them
the mayor and the mayor finally
complaint and then all that stuff
happened and then they found out that
the guy who snitched also had sex with
her oh my god oh so he was just like I'm
a tattletale yeah and then they're like
wait but you're also part of it no I'm
not yeah he's stupid where was this at
Laverne Tennessee in Tennessee because I
I just remember one day like three days
straight memes [__] oh dude it didn't
mean to death yeah it's so funny yeah
it's really funny but yeah so the thing
is she's actually married to park ranger
and uh wow yeah they I guess these cops
were under the impression that they had
became a real cops oh but they're not
and then they know I mean this is a
story they noticed at one point when she
was making out with like one of the like
one of the other girls I guess not even
one of the guys I got a party and he got
visibly upset and the other guys were
like oh maybe it's not an open
relationship oh so come to this point
maybe he was upset because he was like
only guys stop kissing girls maybe yeah
maybe there's a difference between an
open relationship and just like kind of
like sledding out at a party in front of
a lot of other people you're
embarrassing me could be so then they
get to this point where she's fired
these guys are let go uh by the way
that's a small town so all the cops are
gone the firing of these cops has
diminished the force in that town by 10
a little more than that so they're
higher and then the cops and then the
crooks are there are like
the crook is the one that snitched yeah
so the crazy thing it gets crazier right
what do you say
it's crazy it might not be you might
think it's
this whole thing this is just normal all
right the husband is trying to make it
work still ah what
hour
now who's protecting trees and stuff
hey we need Park Rangers man you know
Smokey the Bear was a parking what if he
was doing that [__] too with the other
Park Rangers yeah maybe park rangers are
a little loose you know maybe they're
boning down that's like the bad Channel
high school they're just out in the
forest [__] all day and that's yeah
dude look at her I'm the most pissed
that some guy ruined a good thing yep
yeah there's all these people what is
that sir just I swear I didn't suck that
dick all six of them oh what's up with
girls this year with onion heads like
getting so much promotion
they all got a [__] head that's like
this shape dude yeah Maraca it was that
[__] FDX [__] girlfriend got an
onion yeah they keep they keep comparing
the two of them that's the ranger right
there yeah he's a ranger man poor guy
Dude any such a sweetheart he's like
we're gonna try to make it work after
[__] seeing like viral memes of your
wife being like
how did she get a job now though like
what is she gonna do [__] only fans dude
she probably crush it now like if she
were to do that she'd probably they'd
probably make a pretty good amount hell
yeah really really big show America the
land of opportunity because of the
novelty because of the story if they do
it soon enough you guys are [__] not
just the guys in the room but in general
you guys are [__] disgusting you guys
not just the guys in the room but that's
how they ball now because there's
[__] idiots that are willing to pay
for it that is [__] wild yeah they're
[__] dumb it's it's kind of like what
cat was saying about only fans there's
people who go on there because they want
to see the Meltdown of things not
necessarily you know it's entertainment
it's like it's not just it's all of the
above so it's like if if you want to see
this further like simmer into
nothingness like only fans would be the
last step for them and people would want
to indulge in that like sadness
especially with this story yeah because
she has a lot going for her going into
only fans like she's banging everybody
you know everybody wants to see it's
already a sexual story yeah so is this
crazy because it happened on the job
with so many people because like that's
what makes it illegal yeah
right yeah all the dudes but I feel like
I've heard this a lot though with cops
and like they're just [__] each other
all day it's definitely more taboo for
it to be like you know you're supposed
to be like in uniform that I think that
comes with a certain stigma that makes
it more sexier that does make it a
little but they do call it your partner
yeah this is my partner like why do they
gotta call them Partners Anthony I don't
know I mean prom King because I say
that's my partner no that's your partner
I'm saying that um that doesn't fit
there we're looking at this very often
next time next time we're looking at
this very very wrong okay please help us
okay so number one they're public
servants right yeah and it's their
public duty to serve not only the
community but each other and so it's a
high stress environment when you're out
there making sure that homeless people
aren't defecating in front of people's
homes or like you're pulling over people
and then they're trying to shoot at you
so it's like hey man sometimes when
you're stressed out you need a nut that
makes sense and then she's like let me
help you relieve you of your duties oh
[__] you're stressed out too oh [__]
right stressed out too
everyone's stressed bro so why is she
getting a bad rep if she's she should
get a trophy yeah best partner of the
year you that's why we're not worried
about her we're worried about the
[__] who broke the blue Veil
the guy that ruined a good thing that
[__] the guy with the hair
speaks truth because most cops be dying
in their 50s and [__] from high stress
imagine if she just extended people's
Lifeline just a little bit and herself
because they say sex be making people
live longer like what's more important
let's say they're all highly decorated
cops right now you lose like you're
starting five
and then now crime rate goes through the
roof [__] barber shops getting broken
into shit's getting stolen not the bar
what do you do what's more important do
you want a safe City
with cops that [__] each other or do you
want a dangerous city and the cops don't
touch it yeah the cops [__] each
other sounds like they're gonna be a lot
happier too going to work and you want a
happy cop on the job and maybe more
people will sign up to be cops you know
there's their shortage right now so
what's the compromise you just make a
little [__] room in the station why not
why not a little [__] they got it out of
jail for conjugal visits you're gonna
let the criminals [__] but not the cops
yep that ain't Fair why don't you do
that that's a really good point why huh
why did the prisoners get the [__] and
not the cops
but I do think maybe they shouldn't [__]
on the clock because what if they're
like there's a 9-1-1 call and they're
like oh Joe you can't keep playing with
my emotions like this bro no I can't
come on which which cop do you get more
pissed at the one who like uh like
getting training day or whatever that
movie is where where you no no you don't
this training day like that that's one
of the greatest movies ever made bro
the Denzel cop yeah okay I'm gonna keep
going okay so the idea uh uh it was
Russell Crowe it's not Chinese it's
Russell Crowe where he [__] finds the
money American Gangster movie
[Laughter]
like a cop [__] riding out other cops
because like maybe they like found like
money or Contraband and they were kind
of moving [__] in the [__] like you
know that's a big No-No or ratting out
people for [__] see that's it that's
more [__] that's more [__] [__] is
just [__] daps with your genitals if
you're telling me I can't go hey what's
up man what's up dog it's just like that
just dabbing with genitals what's up
with that but also it's a Thai massage
you're not stealing [__] evidence and
drugs and [__] so this guy's gonna get
it worse right well he's he's he was
double dipping though he was he was
getting some of the action and then he
snitched so that I'm saying more so in
terms of what's worse like who you more
pissed at those guys the Americans no no
for ready for for ready
no he's saying if you're a cop yeah
because he was talking about the uniform
right if you're a cop which rules are
more bendable and I'm like these this
one is stealing evidence and [__]
moving money around yeah that's a big
note that's chill oh genital dabs is
cool it is that's
chill oh that is Chill yeah no what part
said yeah exactly I'm with him
you know what I'm saying you guys are
married or something you know you guys
are [__] very mean I'm his Queen yeah
you are you're Queen what do we have
King in the room do we have a king in
the room right here queen king you know
what I mean I like genital daps I like
that
I think I think more cops should General
dabs right now nah I'm not trying to do
that with you
[Laughter]
[Music]
laughs